[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
what happened to your finger i got a cat
scratch me
is this i i really got a maine [ __ ] why
did you get a cat just so i can say [ __ ]
let's clear the air yeah everyone thinks
because of the cleveland television
interview that you're gay and you're not
gay
i think they stopped doing interviews
because no
oh yeah come on segora's got a great one
bobby lee
there she's still she's the best
interviewer in morning tv if you ask me
do you still do morning tv oh yeah i do
it every week and i hate it and i've
done a million of those but no one ever
put them on youtube and that one just
hit that's did they put it on youtube i
i think i asked him to because it went
well and she was such a pro whatever her
name is abigail or clarence i really hit
home with you apparently yeah yeah but
she was so good and she deserves half
the anal
i'm gonna let that sit
growing up like people i knew had cats
and every time i'd go to their house i
just never
i never enjoyed him i just something
about him i couldn't get over that hump
of like
yeah cats are like blacks you either
love them or hate them and what if you
do both what if you love and hate them
that's tough what color is your cat
black
is that on purpose oh yeah uh diversity
you gotta yeah you gotta have it in the
house i'm getting so good at drinking
you know just from doing it past 13 or
14. that you know like oh i got a good
buzz on if i drink any more i'll be
crazy hungover and i'll be over the line
and or whatever just i'm good right here
yeah i've had a drink with you and
you're not a guy you're actually really
good about having just enough you're
like a guy who knows how to have just
enough now not to say that like i want
to go don't you i want to push the line
but i know just like i alright i got a
rental car uh if i keep going i'll bang
this uh dude or whatever so i got in the
rental car by the way yeah which hurts
charges for now oh yeah you can't just
[ __ ] do the rental car it used to be
a great they used to have a cleanup
policy yeah well it's hard to get jizz
out of fabric it is well do that i get
leather seats
upgrade upgrade baby heat it and then
really
yeah that's a petri dish so now you're
touring around la doing a bunch of
different podcasts but they're all
pretty [ __ ] in comparison to this one i
mean you've done a few marin
bad bad bad bad bad bobby lee bad stop
beijing
well start it there you go start it with
him you can start it
i think you can you're not allowed to
hate asians if you don't know them but
if you know them like i know him i can
hate him good point he's mine yeah he's
my little asian yeah he's short round
he's my little dumpling i can say
whatever i want because he's my friend
he's your egg that's right yeah no no
get out there girls fight back yeah
that's what i say fight back take a
swing pay a bill pay a bill pay a bill
is that a gripe that you have do you do
do you pay for everything everything
yeah you do pay for every dinner oh yeah
does she even try
every now and then she'll get like a
taco you know and she's like oh i got
this taco and you're like thanks where
were you for the uh the steak dinner
yeah i remember when i did whenever i
took you to nobu
yeah yeah give me a reach or a thanks or
a hug or a handy yeah but that's a
that's a part of a quality that'll never
even out and we just like silently know
it you know right that's something that
we're like i want women to have
uh equal treatment as humans and equal
pay and all these things then you go but
um
you know they've never felt the black
book you know what i mean like that
thing that's such a that's such an
innocuous item whenever that thing gets
dropped whenever that book gets dropped
i'm always like i wonder i wonder how
instinctively because you always know
they always drop it right in front of a
dude of course and i always want to push
it over and go how do you know did you
do it to her yeah yeah exactly why is
the pressure on me i always do the thing
in front of her i had a girl tell me i
love when women are just honest with you
like friends and the like the one girl's
like you go on a date with a girl just
pay you'll it'll have you help you get
laid it'll be a much better chance just
pay and i'm like all right but what
about all that she's like i know it's
dumb just do it and you're like all
right and she said if you ever look
cheap in front of a girl it'll the vag
just dries up i get it i get it but then
you have to be honest about the the the
idea of certain feminine points where
you're like exactly that's hey man
feminism has a million holes in it let
me see let's be honest for the
progression of women's rights you're
like okay sure but also i've talked
about this on stage you know i want to
fill those holes how come i don't do all
of them every single one knows your
mouth yeah
i'm kevin hart queef it up baby wow
pretty good good pretty good man
seeing you do it i really hate myself
this is mark my favorite marcus hey i'm
gay
i'm gay that's my out theo vaughn's a
millionaire who's theovan uh he's this
uh redneck guy oh the heck the hiccup
yeah yeah yeah man [ __ ] yeah yeah
dude my dad used to [ __ ] live inside
of a water tower dude he'd swim to the
top like every morning for air just go
back down baby dude we were born
yeah i know that they're like you're
killing the earth now it's like yeah
you're in perpetuity you're killing the
[ __ ] earth it's so we're distracted
by all like the straws remember the
straws were the biggest deal they're
batting by the way now they're back yeah
they're back it was just that one photo
of that [ __ ] coke snorting turtle
that we all fell in love with and then
we all got rid of them one turtle by the
way one turtle i used to say that on
stage show me the shells where are all
these dead turtles
what a lie strewn across the shore they
made it sound like it was millions of
turtles were dying yeah it was [ __ ]
it's like bill burr says it's all cut
with your [ __ ] like if i make a
monkey joke and somebody goes that's
racist i'm like no no you are because
your brain heard monkey and went to this
group you know i wasn't even thinking
that right i was at the bronx zoo in my
brain seeing an actual monkey like i
actually saw a monkey yes you went to a
place of negative nonsense yeah yeah i
mean he was eating chicken but uh still
i get it right that's a great exhibit by
the way oh yeah yeah i like that fried
chicken monkey
exhibit the club sucks the manager sucks
but i'll get a meal so i go what do i
get and the guy goes you got to get the
swordfish and i go great bring it on he
goes you know there's a good wine that
pairs well it's like bringing on the
wine so i must add like five glasses of
wine i got the swordfish i got a dessert
he gives me the check it was like 280.
like what do you upsold me
i was trying to i work here i'm the
headliner and i had to pay for it you
did i paid what could i do you could
tell him to go [ __ ] himself he was
paying me later in the week i needed it
but nothing really that was probably
your whole check it was half of it yeah
yeah that sucks i know it was crazy but
i was like man showbiz is tough those
days were losing money when i used to
lose money was really heartbreaking yeah
i had an emotional breakdown in the car
i was driving
doing a triple run out here and i had
emotional breakdown i pulled over the
side off a [ __ ] reno i was on my way
to montana i just broke down man i
couldn't do it anymore because i barely
had enough to have gas to get up there
and i just was losing it mentally i was
just
and also it came on the heels if i got i
had gotten a speeding ticket i got
pulled up
that takes everything you got those
speeding tickets oh now we're begging
with please i did i begged him so bad
i'm just a comedian i'm just going up to
boise or whatever wherever i was
wherever i was oh billings
heard of you like no [ __ ] that's why i'm
broke yeah that's why there's four
different wheels on this hyundai sonata
no [ __ ] you've never [ __ ] heard of me
these are all stolen from different uh
different [ __ ] body shops i'm riding
on the donut you know about those you
pick
now leave me be i got to go bomb and now
i did i went and ate [ __ ] in my in my
and they remember when they were doing
lie credits when they're like you've
seen this guy yes like
it's like comedy central hbo abc nbc
it's like you've been on nothing you've
been on nothing and youtube wasn't even
around so you had nothing to even fake
it to prove it i remember i called my
mom crying once asking her for five i
knew i was like i need 500 bucks i can't
pay the rent yada yada and we don't do
that in my family same there's no asking
for help or showing emotion and it was
it it was tough and she was like take it
jesus right like get out of here because
you are so desperate yeah that's how bad
it was you know it was new york it was
freezing cold i'm living in a [ __ ] box
with rats it was hell
and now look at you
fancy here i am with my hyundai valester
celeste hyundai molester yeah i got the
honda diddler donna diddler outside
uncle honda so it's about memories for
you yeah memories are all we have yeah
well that's not all we have that's true
present is a lot more important i feel
like than the past
yeah i guess but what is the present
people say that i'm like present's gone
no you're in it right now this is it
this is it are you enjoying yourself in
the podcast i'm having a great time all
right well then this is it but
eventually this will be over it doesn't
matter then you're onto a next thing but
now it's a memory
but it can be and not only is it a
memory it's documented that's why i love
this well this is a capsule yeah this is
important yes this gives you a piece of
of uh this gives you a piece of who you
really are that gets to sit on a thing
for the rest of time i love that yeah
and that's how you get canceled that's
exactly well you're going to get
canceled oh no doubt i want you to look
right in that camera and say i'm ready
to get canceled
me and shane gillis are writing
something yeah what do you what is it
what is it what is it it's called
chinatown right yeah
how's the mood around that in this town
called a chick in the army there it is
um it's a war-torn it's a war film you
know it's weird because i feel like it's
kind of coming back around but like
there's a weird vibe now i don't and la
doesn't seem to have this or i didn't
see it or feel it but like a couple of
guys from like
the other side came to a comedy club and
you could feel when they walked in it
was like awkward and you're like
are you guys comics why am i nervous
around you what do you mean the other
side be more clear like the the side
that wants to cancel you uh you know and
you're like we're all telling zingers
what is your big agenda on ruining
people's lives and in their minds
they're so
gung-ho on like we're saving the world
here this guy said [ __ ] we gotta ruin
his life you're like i'm not a bad
person i love asians it's a word i'm a
i'm a clown right what are you crazy
right this is your life right this is
you're sick right this is your illness
you think i'm a weirdo you have this
thing where you want to ruin someone's
life you got problems right and uh like
also where do you think rappers are
going around going hey you talking about
killing that guy that that's kind of
mean like you're an artist i'm an artist
let let's be artists stop right
critiquing go help somebody go help the
world if you're such a savior i send uh
my wife limp dick pics i'll never do
hard that's love make her work for it
yeah yeah i mean make her build up to
something have you heard my dick pic
story no maybe eight years ago i hooked
up with this gal it was like this
passionate weekend on the road it was
amazing she was way out of my league it
was highlight of my life
so we'd kind of communicate after a few
weeks of me leaving and she'd be like
send me a dick pic
send her dick pic whatever no big deal
eight months later we stopped talking
whatever
somebody d or uh tweets at me asks me
hey is this your dick and it was a photo
of my dick some random guy like
minnesota but a good photo no less yeah
but it's still my dick so it's not great
but i saw my sheets and that's what did
it i was like ah those are my dinosaur
sheets and so uh that's my race car bed
i know that bed anywhere yeah i just
didn't respond and it kind of you know
flew off into the twitter ether but uh
jesus seeing your own dick on a public
platform is terrifying that's a bummer
and you know it was mine well you got a
nice penis though it's all right it's
fine it's a civic it's a civic yeah it's
like it'll get you places it's reliable
but you know it's not going to win a
race i just got robbed in the west
village about it about a year ago and it
brought all of it back and you know it's
very my girl who i live with she's from
cape cod so she's like this is crazy
i've never even thought about this and
the cops came and i live in the west
village was a nice neighborhood and the
cops couldn't have been nicer when i was
a kid the cops were like a pain in the
ass like keep it moving you know
swinging the baton and these people were
like oh my god we're so sorry we're
gonna we're gonna catch this guy i was
like what's this this is a new cop yeah
but they didn't catch him they caught
them oh they did they got a fingerprint
off of my uh
drawer chest of drawers and he took a
lot i had a lot of cash in there he took
all of it what are you doing keeping so
much cash in your house i thought it was
cool having a drawer full of cash what
do you andrew dice clay what the [ __ ]
are you doing i had some shrooms in
there i had some shrooms i guess weed i
get but it was just it was like my cool
guy too much cash be honest be right it
was uh it was
more than five grand less than 10. okay
say that i always say you should keep
around
well okay i should i say there should be
a couple of grand at any given time in
case of an emergency yeah but but
about five you're getting now you're
getting into the [ __ ] territory it's
a bad move it felt like he knew it felt
and of course your brain starts going
like did i talk about this and am i an
idiot is this a fan how did he get in
how do you know my part blah blah blah i
live in a big building with a bunch of
units and he knew about my cash it felt
weird i had fireworks in there i had
brass knuckles i had a porno you know it
was like a eighth grade drawer yeah i
was just gonna say was this a time
capsule from when you were in junior
high yeah and it was fun to just open it
on a saturday morning hung over and go
oh that's pretty cool and then close it
stuff yeah i don't know what i was going
to do with it or what but i had it i
loved seeing it so i don't ever watch
the award shows but i do think they're
very funny in the sense of um
what what's turning to happen in the in
society i think it's great i saw us on
twitter i saw you know they throw up
like a little speech clips on twitter on
twitter my favorite was someone was
talking very adamantly about about like
how many black people get killed by the
cops every day and it was like very like
emotional and very and then his partner
steps up to the mic and he's like we
want to thank netflix
[Laughter]
ted sarandos i was like dude the
juxtaposition is so funny to be on these
social platforms and then be like also
we want to thank all the producers and
everyone that made millions of dollars
on it it's just
it's kooky they can't even see it like
how can you not see it you're on stage
holding a go gold trophy and a 10
million dollar gown right and you're
like it's hard out there things are
tough you're like come on there's a guy
working at a mill it's on it's i
understand why people want to get use
their platform to have a message but it
gets diluted when the when the event
itself
is so disingenuous right like
the event is disingenuous if it was an
event for a charity i'd be like this is
a great time to make a big speech yeah
but this thing isn't for charity this is
for to tap each other on the back and
say you won you're better than everybody
else that does the thing and six years
ago we were all blowing harvey like look
at that guy he's the king we love him
seinfeld was big but the show when i saw
the show it blew my mind
yeah like i would watch it with my
parents and they hate everything and
they like that and i liked it and that
meant are you and jerry friendly yeah we
text probably you know once every two
weeks
wow yeah yeah pretty good is that
something that you'd like you you step
back and you go wow that's kind of weird
i've gotten a text from him every time
the ring every time i get uh every time
i get a nick pick i get a jerry text do
you and jerry text like that ever yeah
one tick pic he's uncircumcised which i
couldn't believe what time yeah
wait a minute for is there ever a moment
that he he's very is he very playful and
joking are the texts a little bit
serious they're pretty cut and dry you
know he's old he's business and i've
tried to be playful and he'll give me
like a ha and i'm like i'll take it but
then this time she doesn't respond and
you want to kill yourself right you want
to kill yourself yeah i mean you just
your your whole night is consumed with
like oh that last one why did i do that
and then i've done some before i'm like
you shouldn't send this
i sent it and it turned out okay so
sometimes i took a risk and it worked
out and sometimes it was horrible
right was he a hero at all oh yeah oh
yeah yeah
see he wasn't for me i don't i don't
mean a disrespect i just he never was
i loved the show but not as the comedian
wasn't the thing that i loved i loved
the show so much well i think he's so
important because when we pre when we
imitate stand-up we're doing him which
is a that's a testament you know like
what's the deal
you know that's him right so that's got
to say a lot
[Music]
[Music]
face it's a dark place
[Music]